What exactly is the meaning of belief in
alqatar?
As far as belief in kadar is concerned,
it is one of the pillars of Im believing
in kadar. And there are four points that
are to be noted in the belief of kadar.
Number one that Allah knows everything.
Allah has knowledge of everything, the
past, the present and the future.
He has knowledge of things which are
general as well as specific. He has
knowledge from eternity to eternity. So
Allah is the one who knows everything.
He has me. Point number two, Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala has written this in
the fools in a tablet preserved. And
both these points of belief of that is
mentioned in surah hajj chapter number
22 verse number 17 that knowest not thou
that Allah subhananau wa ta'ala knows
everything in the heavens and the earth
and indeed it is kept in his record and
for Allah it is easy that means number
one that Allah knows everything and
number two it's kept in his record it's
mentioned in surah hajj chapter 22 verse
number 17 it's mentioned in say muslim
volume number four in the book of Kadar
had number 6016
that the messenger of Allah said that
Allah ordained the measure of the
creation of the universe 50,000 years
before the heavens and the earth were
created. It's further mentioned in sun
abu volume number three had number 4683
that Allah subhananau wa ta'ala first
created the pen and said to it write the
pen replied oh lord what should I write
and subhan wa ta'ala wrote the decree
the kadar of all the things till the
beginning of the hour till the beginning
of the day of judgment these are the
first two points the third point of
kadar is that everything happens with
the will of Allah subhana wa t'ala.
Everything as Allah says in the Quran in
surah kasas chapter number 28 verse
number 68 Allah subhanaa t creates and
chooses as he wills. It's mentioned in
surah Ibrahim chapter number 14 verse
number 27 that Allah does whatever he
wills and it's also mentioned in surah
burj chapter number 85 verse number 16.
Allah is the doer of all he intends. So
here we come to know that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala whatever he intends
he can do. Whatever he wants he can do.
And further it's mentioned in surah
Imran chapter number three verse number
six that Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
shapes you in the womb as he pleases.
It's mentioned in surah nisa chapter
number four verse number 19 that if
Allah w you would have given power to
them and they would have fought you.
It's mentioned in surah anam chapter
number 6 verse number 112 Allahh says
that if Allah w they would not have done
it. The fourth point in the belief of
kadar is that all things that happen are
created by Allah subhana wa ta'ala in
the essence in the attribute and in the
movement as Allah says in the Quran in
surah als chapter number 39 verse number
62 that Allah is the creator of
everything and he is the guardian and
disposer of all affairs.
It's further mentioned in surah furan
chapter number 25 verse number two that
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala created the
heavens and the earth in due proportion.
It's mentioned surah safhat chapter
number 37 verse number 96 that Allah
subhananaa tala created you and your
handiwork
and further just because Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala is the person who has created
everything happen that does not mean
that it interferes with our free will
yet have our free will and there are
many vers which talk about that that we
have a free will and the Sharia says
that and we know in our day-to-day life
that we have a free will Allah further
says in the Quran in surah bakar chapter
number two verse number 223 talking
about approaching the spouses that you
can approach your tilt the way you like
and when you like it that means you have
a free will it's further mentioned in
surah tagun chapter number 64 verse
number 16
that fear Allah as much as you can
listen to him and obey him and it's
mentioned in surah bakar chapter number
two verse number 286
that Allah subhanana wa ta'ala does not
lay a burden greater than a person can
bear and he earns every good that he
does and he suffers every evil that he
earns. So based on this every human
being has a free will
and
we see that in day-to-day life for
example there are certain things which
are governed by Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala he has fixed certain things about
that about life everything else Allah
has given a free will if I want I can
lift my hand if I want I can bring it
down if I want I can walk if I want I
can sit it's my will but certain things
for example The heart beating it beats
according to the will of Allah subhana
wa ta'ala. I can't if I want to stop my
heart from beating I cannot do it. For
example, if I feel cold, I shiver if I
want to I cannot stop it. It is the will
of Allah subhanana wa tala. So Allah has
given a free will to the human beings.
That's the reason if a person does
something evil or does a sin, he
responsible for it. And Allah has given
the guidance in the Quran what is good
and what is bad. Zakov.